okay let's get back to people waiting to
chat on discord davidpakman.com
discord
let's go next to our friend issa from
london isa welcome back to the program
hey david how's it going it's going well
um you know i was thinking that loads of
uh uh gun owners in the u.s they say
that one of the reasons they want to own
weapons
is to protect themselves from an overly
intrusive government yes um like a
tyrannical government um so i'm not i
don't know too much about this but i was
wondering uh if say if the u.s
government decided to
like you know launch an attack on its
population wouldn't they use military
technology that
that would be it would be meaningless to
use rifles against that kind of stuff
that's my opinion as well yeah and this
has been brought up before which is
uh if the you know and it's funny
because
many of the same people that say that
love having the biggest most powerful
military so they simultaneously are like
we need our military to have all the
best most powerful stuff
and also if it becomes tyrannical
we need to have our assault rifles to
protect ourselves which number one
wouldn't really even be useful because
the government has such overwhelming
force but also if you suspect that that
may happen with the government why would
you want them to have such a powerful
army like it's both idiotic and also
contradictory it doesn't make any sense
yeah yeah good point i agree i i think
it's um
it's a bit odd how uh
loads of uh american gun owners
uh feel like
uh their sense of freedom is is tied
into being able to own firearms yes and
they're not only their sense of freedom
their sense of identity
yeah
yeah
uh all right well thank you very much
for the call
thank you all right there's issa from
london always great
to hear from our friends on the other
side of the pond as many of you know i'm
a busy person i don't always have the
exact correct nutritional plan for my
meals every single day and that's why i
also take a multivitamin and a couple of
supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit
time-consuming which is why athletic
greens is just fantastic and they're one
of our sponsors i've been using the
athletic greens since last year it just
really simplifies nutrition i just do a
scoop of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75
high quality vitamins and minerals and
my probiotics and it's all from whole
food sources i drink it in the morning i
know i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning it when what time of day do i
need to take each one i just get it all
with one scoop you can put it in a
smoothie you can drink it straight it
tastes great and then i'm just good for
the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below